I want to spend some time today digging
into the situation with North Korea and
we've had sort of over the weekend like
day after day of major news coming out
of North Korea after I I don't even
really know where to start but let's at
least pick it up with Friday which is
when North Korean leader Kim jong-un and
South Korean president moon jae-in met
in person and let's first I guess start
off with the facts and what took place
and then we can think about it and think
about what the analysis might be and
sort of what we can expect in the next
few weeks and really the geopolitical
implications overall are the really
important part as well as the
implications for the North Korean people
who are the people that have actually
suffered the most in what has taken
place there over the last many decades
so they had their meeting Friday Kim
jong-un moon jae-in news comes out that
the the meeting between North and South
Korea went incredibly well Kim jong-un
is ready to end the Korean War
potentially to shut down North Korea's
nuclear weapons program and the ending
of the war was something that I noticed
a lot of people weren't sort of
understanding it's a hugely symbolic
issue the Korean War has not officially
ended despite the fact that an armistice
was signed in the early 1950s so that
that is significance we also learned
yesterday that during the meeting Kim
jong-un reportedly told the South Korean
president that he would be willing to
completely abandon his nuclear weapons
program if the United States number1
agreed to formally end the Korean War
and number two promised not to invade
North Korea we're gonna talk about that
in depth in a moment and Kim jong-un
also said that he'd be willing to invite
South Korean and American experts and
journalists basically to watch the
shutting down of North Korea's only
known underground nuclear test site
sometime next month so things apparently
willing to move very quickly with Kim
jong-un and this really gets directly to
the analysis that just has to be done
here there was also a report from Friday
claiming that they had agreed to work
towards a future of unification
and to a denuclearized Korea so first
and foremost I want to be really clear
my analysis is being done in good faith
in case anyone was going to accuse me of
doing this analysis in bad faith I have
no interest whatsoever in denying Donald
Trump credit where credit is due but I
also want to be sure that we're not
giving Donald Trump credit where it has
not actually been earned so from the
beginning of this entire thing my sense
was and this wasn't my original analysis
right it's simply based on knowing the
history lots of people have said the
same thing my sense was that the idea
here was a combination of North Korea
number one planning to do the exact same
type of manipulation that they've done
in the past with these negotiations
combined possibly with number two seeing
an opportunity specifically because of
the irrational and unhinged nature of
Donald Trump to trigger more of a
reaction from the Oval Office than North
Korea has gotten from previous American
presidents what do I mean by North
Korea's normal manipulations well I
mentioned it last week right there are
always caveat with North Korea let's
talk through some of them right since
they are the exact implicit caveats that
I also already mentioned last week
number one North Korea is willing to
denuclearize and consider the nuclear
the Korean War over if the following
conditions are met number one
denuclearization of Korea okay in the
past when North Korea says the
denuclearization of Korea South Korea
doesn't have nuclear weapons what they
mean is no US troops in South Korea
since the United States is a nuclear
power and has a military presence in
South Korea is the u.s. going to leave
South Korea completely hard to imagine
but maybe we will have to see what the
Trump administration is willing to agree
to number two another condition from Kim
jong-un the US must agree not to invade
I can't think of any president that
would make a pre-emptive declaration
that they will not invade any country
diplomatically it's a no-win presidents
don't tend to do that Donald Trump
specifically has also said it's a really
bad idea to even hint at what you will
or won't be doing or to
anything off the table so certainly
unless Trump is ready to go completely
opposite what his doctrine has been
until now which he maybe because he has
no real actual genuine political
philosophies but at least from what he
what he said how on earth does Trump now
say the United States is willing to say
we will not invade North Korea doesn't
make any sense and also how can that
even be something that you put in
writing do you say we agree not to
invade North Korea for X amount of time
or ever or no matter what North Korea
does even many of the most extreme
pacifists would understand why
geopolitically something like this would
be very very risky now the way that it
could be done is that the US could sign
like a peace treaty for example it gets
ratified through Congress a peace treaty
with North Korea u.s. the US has
typically not violated peace treaties
there are some exceptions but typically
they have not so that's a way that it
could be done but it's very hard
imagining Trump's gonna be the guy to do
that but I've been wrong before and I
could be wrong again so let's now look
at the concept of reunification I don't
know what it is that Kim jong-un had in
mind when he said reunification but
historically the reunification narrative
from North Korea has been one where they
imagine or hope that South Korea will
agree to some combination of effectively
ending a capitalist system and becoming
economically like North Korea and/or the
Kim family becoming the rulers of one
Korea that includes what today is South
Korea that's not gonna happen right
that's simply not going to happen so
those are the paths to reunification
that North Korea has referred to
favorably in the past for South Korea
and for most of the developed world
reunification of South Korea is more of
Korea is likely to be the Kim regime
relinquishing power how you work out the
logistics of that at this point I don't
know and North Korea becoming sort of
part of South Korea in a sense and
that's what's really concerning about
all of this I obviously hope for the
best this has been one of the worst
humanitarian crises
in a very very long time which we've
been covering for years but historically
the Kim regime has made similar
statements and claims and so-called
agreements that have gone nowhere
because they have because of how they
define a lot of these terms the theme
has been agreeing to do things that are
difficult to monitor demanding things
that are basically non-starters for
other countries to do and we're
definitely seeing some of that here it's
a good opportunity to restate that we've
learned that North Korea's nuclear
testing facility was hugely damaged by
an earthquake we still don't know the
full extent of that but if it's true
that would be a really good reason for
Kim jong-un to say let's agree to shut
down something that just broke and see
what political benefit we can get from
it and maybe we could even get other
countries to help us with the cleanup or
dealing with whatever Fallout and
radiation might be happening as a
consequence from those from that
potentially a hugely damaged nuclear
testing site as far as who gets credit
for this and this has been a big topic
of conversation my sense is that it's
mostly South Korea we actually don't
know at this point if China has been
involved behind the scenes we know that
Chinese President Xi has made it clear
that China isn't going to tolerate North
Korean nonsense any longer it's possible
that that's something that's gone on
behind the scenes we know that publicly
he's consolidated power removed term
limits we don't know what privately
China may have done diplomatically with
North Korea and then there's the Trump
factor right there's the question of
whether Trump's erratic behavior has
influenced Kim jong-un in some way I
don't know the answer right we'll know
once it becomes more public whether
Trump is being played here John Bolton
Trump's new national security adviser
says we're aware of the ways in which
Kim jong-un might be attempting to
manipulate we're not falling for it my
hope is that something positive comes of
this right but if it seems too good to
be true it usually is and a wholesale
180 degree change from Kim jong-un even
if that nuclear that damaged nuclear
test site is a factor it's not likely to
materialize in practice it's great that
it's being discussed but the eye
dia that in three months we will be
rapidly moving towards total
denuclearization of North Korea
reunification of North and South Korea
an agreement from the United States not
to invade etc etc it's not the most
likely scenario one other x-factor here
we should never underestimate Donald
Trump's ability to mess things up no
matter how good things are looking and
this is why it's unusual to bring in an
American president so early on in the
process typically when someone like an
American president meets with someone in
the position of Kim jong-un ninety nine
percent of the agreement has been pre
negotiated to protect the American
president from a situation where they
show up and they end up being
manipulated by the foreign leader by the
foreign often authoritarian dictator
type and no deal is made and it really
was used to the benefit of Kim jong-un
or whoever just to have a seat at the
table with Donald Trump and not end up
actually agreeing to terms that the
United States would find acceptable so
that's an interesting element to this
we'll be following it
I am withholding judgment for the time
being as to how much responsibility and
credit lies with Donald Trump here but
I'm interested in hearing from you what
specifically do you think Trump has done
if anything that affords him credit for
the progress that has been made so far
I'm open to hearing views from the
audience about this including on Twitter
you can find me on Twitter at D Pakman
the show is on twitter at david pakman
show and we have a fantastic program for
you today the video you just finished
watching was made possible by you
through the membership program you can
sign up for membership at david
pakman.com slash membership we are
viewer supported independent media you
can use the coupon code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership